ah it's a beautiful day for a hike in
the woods
there's nothing but the fresh air
trees and killer bears
oh
my
what would it be like to meet up with a
bear
in what ways would different kinds of
bears attack
and
what could you do to stay alive
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were attacked by a bear
close encounters with bears
don't always lead to them attacking you
there are only about 40 bear attacks
around the world every year
give or take
but if you do get attacked you're in big
trouble
and each type of bear could have a
different dinner plan for you
you could run into a 58 kilogram female
black bear
or a
315 kilogram grizzly bear with her cubs
or if you're in the arctic you might
face a vicious
590 kilogram polar bear
whoa
staring up at the gaping jaws of any
bear could be the last thing you see
will your next move save your life
after a peaceful night of camping you
unzip your tent and find you've made a
big mistake
you've left some food out and now you've
been graced with the presence of a
dangerous visitor
it's a black bear
you gasp and freeze in place but
don't worry yet
black bears usually don't attack in a
sudden encounter
mostly they attack in self-defense so
don't get too close
you slowly step out of the tent and
scoot a few steps back to give the bear
some space but you're not far enough
away
now the bear is showing aggression with
some grunts
you could run but then you'd have to
leave all your stuff behind
instead you spot a nearby tree and think
i could climb that and be safe
well as you dash toward the tree the
bear is right behind you
luckily you were closest to the tree
with running speeds up to 40 kilometers
an hour
black bears are fast
you scramble up a few branches and look
down to see the bear climbing too
yeah black bears can climb so
now you'd be screwed
when it's close enough to attack the
black bear swipes its massive claws at
you
a black bear's claws are good for
climbing but they aren't that sharp so
it's the bear's strength you'd worry
about
black bears can move boulders weighing
140 kilograms with one paw
and one swipe from this bear knocks you
down to the ground
ouch
your surging adrenaline helps you spring
up while the bear is still in the tree
it's time to make a run for it
you'd sprint down the trail until you
couldn't run anymore
you'd need to stop and catch your breath
but
what's that dreadful crunching sound
turning around slowly
you freeze
oh no
it's a grizzly bear with two cubs
the mama bear begins rubbing her body on
a nearby tree
is she just scratching an itch
not quite
she lets out a loud growl
you realize that you've surprised her
and she's being aggressive to protect
her cubs
but you wouldn't have much time to react
this opportunistic hunter charges toward
you at a blazing 64 kilometers per hour
you make a quick evasive move but the
bear swings one of its claws at you
a grizzlies claws aren't razor sharp
since the bear uses them to dig
but they are strong and one hit knocks
you down hard
the grizzly is on top of you and its
body weight keeps you pinned
its massive jaws are about to clamp down
on you
with a force of 8274
kilopascals
you think you're done for and
you might be right
the best thing you could do now is to
play dead
it's a terrifying gamble but it would be
your best shot at surviving the bear
would sniff and slobber all over you
each movement of its paws digging deeper
into your body
but it works
mama grizzly walks back over to her cubs
and you are completely motionless until
you hear the bears crawling off into the
distance
phew you scrambled your feet and run
back to your car
finally you're safe
you survived
not so fast
there's one more type of bear to worry
about
and it has been stalking and hunting you
for prey
it's a male polar bear
wait what
a polar bear follows its prey using its
exceptional sense of smell
so now
you won't be able to hide
and you left your car key with the rest
of your gear at the campsite
after a day of bear attacks
this would be the end of the line
one swipe from the bear's nine and a
half centimeter claws can snap your
spine
then
it would feast on you
as your life drains out of you
you'd suddenly realize something
polar bears are supposed to roam the icy
polar deserts in the arctic circle
that's definitely not where you went
camping
as you snap out of this traumatic
fantasy
you have to face reality as a pair of
day hikers step out of their car and
find you in your dirty pajamas
well at least you weren't attacked by
any other creatures
like
murder hornets
well that would be a story
for another
what if
[Music]